I just was given a bulletin Jack Palance
is now on the Stairmaster we'll keep you
posted during evening he's apparently
he's doing the Ironman event tonight and
if you've never seen him on a bike in
shorts it's something she is currently
giving us chills in the hand that rocks
the cradle and he is making us laugh in
the Addams Family here are Rebecca De
Mornay and Christopher Lloyd
mr. newm De Mornay and I are pleased to
present the Oscar for makeup which Oscar
never wears but you do don't you mr.
Lloyd
just a touch here are three examples of
how makeup artists apply their art from
their original sketches to their final
creations the nominees are Christina
Smith Monty Westmore and greg cannom or
hooked Michael Mills Edward French and
Richard Snell for Star Trek 6 the
undiscovered country Stan Winston and
Jeff dawn for Terminator 2 Judgment Day
the Oscar goes to
where's the envelope the envelope let's
be kidding
will someone give us a hand with the
oven oh please
the award for best achievement and
makeup goes to Stan Winston and Jeff Don
for terminator 2
huh we'd like to thank Steve Laporte
peter toth paul all the people in my
studio especially John rosengrant Shane
Mahan and Richard Landon who've been
with me from the start the guy who sat
in that chair for four hours every day
and made this all work Arnold
Schwarzenegger and the brilliant
director behind it all Jim Cameron thank
you and I'd like to give a special
thanks to the two men who made this
possible for me made this this all
happened tonight Bob and West dawn the
late Bob and West Dawn wherever you are
guys this is for you thank you very much